nosotros les llamamos
[Música]
nosotros amamos a todos amamos a
Estambul
nosotros amamos a Estambul
nuestro viaje empezó en Estambul y
nuestro viaje nos regresa a Estambul
[Música]
Qué gran alegría estar aquí hoy
en un bajo un nuevo cielo
está bajo un nuevo cielo
queridos amigos queridos seguidores en
esta causa
quiero expresar mi más profundo respeto
y mi gratitud a todos ustedes
el presidente
estas elecciones han pasado por la
primera la segunda ronda y ahora
Nosotros sabemos que tenemos la fe de
ustedes
a pesar
de 12 festividades religiosas quiero
verdad agradecerles por llegar acá y
traernos a un momento a una era
democrática una fiesta democrática
porque
eso es por el futuro de nuestros hijos
ustedes expresaron
su deseo para el futuro y quiero
agradecerles por Mostrar su fe en mí
a todos los miembros de nuestra
organización política los jóvenes los
hombres las mujeres los observadores en
las estaciones de votación a esas
personas que supervisaron esta elección
aquellas personas que fueron tan activas
a la hora de demostrar que esta campaña
podría avanzar quiero agradecerles a
ellos especialmente
también quiero felicitarlos a todos
Quiero felicitar a las mujeres
Quiero felicitar a la gente joven
Quiero felicitar a todos aquellos
que creyeron en ese partido acá hermanos
hermanas de nuestra causa sea que vivan
en Turquía o en las fronteras le Quiero
agradecer a todos a todos aquellos que
vinieron a votar en la segunda ronda en
tan altos números Muchas gracias muchas
gracias a todos aquellos que fueron a
votar hoy
Muchas gracias por elegir a nuestro
partido porque al hacerlo han elegido un
camino
a favor de nuestro país por los próximos
años ustedes me han dado la posibilidad
del cargo para cuidar a nuestro país y
yo quiero agradecerles por esa señal a
todos en nuestra nación que votaron por
mí Muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y con el favor de Dios yo voy a
demostrar que soy digno de la fe que
ustedes me han mostrado hoy Así como he
hecho por los últimos 21 años seguiré en
el mismo camino
yo les dije
recientemente que no sería hasta el
domingo
que yo estaría aquí hasta que esté en la
tumba
nosotros dijimos a Dios Qué mal
y no vamos a detenernos en este camino
estamos solamente a la mitad vamos a
llegar al final de esto y vamos a seguir
el trabajo que hemos empezado para
asegurarnos de que Turquía seguirá en
nuestro control y le serviremos a
Turquía
[Aplausos]
si ustedes
quieren Podemos agregar un Bye bye
bye bye bye qué mal
[Música]
Y gracias con Adiós
Ustedes han acogido este llamado y esta
elección de hoy
mostró
el gran afecto que tenemos el uno por el
otro
hemos tomado esta lucha y la hemos
convertido
en determinación para luchar en nombre
de Turquía gracias a ustedes hemos
nombrado hemos logrado que Turquía
sea tan fuerte como un acero inoxidable
un acero y modificable
ahora escúchenme escuchen con cuidado
yo
tengo una historia para contar
Cuántos parlamentos cuántos
parlamentarios habían
1940 146
años después el chp
en términos de oficiales elegidos tenían
como ustedes saben ahora
solo un porcentaje de votos de esos
partidos
que no tienen ni un por ciento de votos
solamente tienen 40 asientos en el
parlamento Qué significa eso
este partido de la República ha tenido
una disminución mínima Ellos dicen que
eran especialistas
hacer cuentas pero haciendo eso han
perdido muchos escaños habiendo perdido
escaños
el chp ahora va
a despedirse de que mal también iba a
pedir una nueva posibilidad el 14 de
mayo
en el 28 de mayo
85 millones de personas
todos en nuestro país
nos han traído esta Victoria
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es gracias a esta Victoria
que todos somos ganadores ya no hay
perdedores los verdaderos ganadores de
hoy somos Turquía la democracia
nuestra economía
no vamos a comprometer nada
mientras se trate de las metas que nos
hemos establecido y estamos entrando en
un nuevo ciclo un siglo fuerte
con los hombres con las mujeres con la
clase trabajadora con los retirados los
jóvenes todos en nuestro país
serán elevados por el entusiasmo que ya
hemos mostrado
y vamos a tomar
esa esperanza
de aquellas personas que comparten
que compartieron su corazón con nosotros
íbamos a luchar en su nombre y vamos a
llevar a cabo esa lucha vamos a llevarla
hacia adelante juntos
con la gente aquí hoy
[Aplausos]
con la gente aquí en esta Plaza hoy
hemos abierto un nuevo capítulo en la
historia de Turquía
[Música]
pueblo de Estambul
yo estoy muy feliz de estar parado
frente a ustedes con compañeros como
ustedes
nosotros juntos todos vamos a celebrar
cada nueva Victoria a medida que
empiecen a llegar
tendremos un 20 24 de aquí en adelante
saben a qué me refiero en 2024
Y es que David
están listos para ganar la elección
local
por eso es que estoy diciendo que el
camino no se ha acabado aún nuestro
viaje aún no se ha acabado
yo dije
y ahora pido
a las fuerzas de seguridad Cuántas
personas están en la plaza de hoy me
dijeron que había 55.000
pero las elecciones vienen
lo importante
es nunca perder la vista de los
objetivos que hemos establecido por
nuestro país como la unidad
un pedido de unidad Por nuestra nación
las elecciones que vimos hoy
reiteran ese mensaje fundamental
con estas elecciones hemos visto una vez
más
que nadie
puede desafiar lo que nuestro país
representa
recientemente el presidente de
azerbaiyán
me llamó
el presidente de la república de
Uzbekistán también me llamó
Primer Ministro de Libia
todos me han llamado y siguen llamándome
uno tras otro
todos para decir que si se necesita
se les llame y ellos vendrán que los
invitemos y ellos vendrán
porque ellos quieren compartir esta
Victoria
sea en el occidente o en el Oriente
Qatar también llamó compartiendo nuestra
dicha
Nadie
puede quitarnos eso nadie puede
quitarnos nuestras libertades
Nadie puede
mirar mal a nuestra nación Nadie puede
insultar a nuestra nación Nadie
puede tomar a nuestra juventud de
nosotros y arrebatarnoslas
Nadie puede criticar a Turquía
y nadie puede interferir en Nuestro
camino
nadie nos detendrá
de nuestra de ser Unidos de ser hermanos
tras haber escuchado nuestra llamado a
la acción nadie romperá Turquía nadie
romperá nuestra voluntad
ahora tenemos que gritarlo para que la
gente pueda escucharnos en coro todos en
Estambul debemos ser oídos hermanos
hermanas
c HP
es un partido
es un partido verdadero
[Música]
hay muchos partidos
en este sistema pero realmente
representan
pueden estas personas intentar incitar
nuestros partidos no no pueden no pueden
porque somos Unidos y somos fuertes
y cada elección
cada elecciones para nosotros un Renacer
porque nuestra familia es Sagrada es
firme y nadie puede herir a nuestra
familia
la violencia en contra de las mujeres
está vetada es ilegal en nuestra nación
y nadie podrá nunca cambiar eso
si intentan cambiarlo nos encontrarán
defendiendo esas libertades
y en los momentos por venir
implementaremos todo lo que hemos
prometido a ustedes lo que le permitimos
al pueblo de Turquía
y con eso
voy a ir a ankara
y en esta ocasión
voy a cambiar su rumbo
[Aplausos]
porque nosotros yo hablaré desde el
Palacio presidencial
Y desde ahí hablaré al mundo
si ustedes me permiten hacerlo
deberemos
hablar muy fuerte porque esto es lo que
podemos hacer si ustedes están
dispuestos levanten su mano en el aire y
muestren que ustedes
están conmigo
Déjenme hacer un pequeño discurso
aquellas personas que fuesen que fueron
víctimas del terremoto
están ahí mis pensamientos y mis
oraciones porque aquellas personas a
pesar de las condiciones en sus ciudades
y pueblos aún fueron a votar quiero
agradecerles por ello como dije en un
año habremos reconstruido los hogares
para todos ellos están listos una sola
nación una sola bandera
una nación
un estado
Nosotros somos uno nosotros estamos
Unidos somos fuertes
estamos juntos somos hermanos y hermanas
juntos
haremos a Turquía de nuevo
[Aplausos]